[Ned] What was that? What was that?
Oh, no!
Ariel!
We're buying a house.
Yes, I know, Bean.
Over the last two years,
we've been looking at a bunch
of different open houses,
but now, we have a baby on the way,
so, it's serious.
We partnered with
realtor.com to give you guys
a three-part series that's
all about our process
of trying to find a house.
We saw a bunch of
different houses last week,
and we picked the Spanish-style fixer-up.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
We wrote a letter saying that
we're expecting a baby soon
and that we loved the neighborhood,
but the question is, Ariel.
[Ariel] Yes?
Did we get the house?
We got the house!
Come on, babe!
Okay, let's go inside.
Something's wrong with the door.
Let me see those keys.
Let's go around the back.
[Ariel] Wait for me.
[Ned] Let's talk about
how we're gonna make
this house our home.
You know what I want?
I want this to be like a big great room.
[Ned] You know where it's like you walk in
you've got a seating area over here.
Then you sort of see like, ahhhh.
[Ariel] Yeah.
We've got the new My Home
section of realtor.com up
with all of this remodeling we're doing.
We're gonna want to track
the value of our home.
But first, let's look at
some design inspiration.
I like the look of this
space, the fireplace
is a really central piece.
[Ariel] Yeah.
So maybe we could take the
brick and paint it white.
[Ariel] I think that would be lovely.
We know the door needs fixing.
[Ariel] Yes.
[Ned] What are we going to do about that?
I, kind of, like this darker color here.
Yeah.
I think we need the really
sort of regal-looking hardware.
Gold accents on a blue door?
That would look really nice.
We can get a big old knocker.
I want a big door knocker.
Like, a big old knocker.
Yeah, do you like big knockers?
Yeah, that's...
Her words, not mine.
This is probably one
of the weirdest spots.
Yeah, it's a passageway from
the hallway to the master,
which is really strange.
We either need to close this door
or put in a hallway.
Yeah.
[Ned] I'm kind of feeling the hallway.
I'm feeling the hallway, too.
And as much as I love it,
I think we might need to
get rid of our paneling.
It's like an '80s den.
This is your house, Bean.
You have a house.
Well, now he's licking his balls, so.
Here is our lovely little
two steps down to...
[Ariel] Our little stairs.
[Ned] Beautiful carpet.
[Ariel] This carpet is going bye-bye.
[Ned] This is the nastiest carpet
I've ever seen.
I'm kind of wondering
what's underneath it.
Dead bodies.
A stack of cash.
Cash, spiders.
A whole lot of boogers.
A lot of boogers.
That's how they made it stick.
Yeah.
As far as master bathrooms
go, it's kind of...
[Ariel] Oh, it's teeny.
It's kind of small.
It's teeny-tiny.
It's a very exciting project.
We're planning on expanding
the exterior walls
of the master bedroom.
All that dirt spot outside,
it's going to be bathroom.
This is the kitchen here,
and it needs a lot of work.
These cabinets, get them out of there.
It looks nasty.
We're gonna take out all of this,
all that, all this,
but it's gonna turn into an entire
open kitchen concept.
[Ariel] I like this countertop.
Like the marble with the gold faucets.
Yeah, that is nice.
Classy.
That's a classy look.
Brass, brass faucets.
Brass, not gold.
The actual kitchen part of
it is gonna go over here.
Yeah.
[Ariel] And then, like three steps away
we're gonna have an island.
It's like boom, boom, boom.
I'm cooking, serving, island.
Eat-in island.
Eat-in island
So like an island
where you can sit.
It's just means you can eat on it.
What have we done,
Ariel? What have we done!
We own this house now.
I like it!
I like it, too.
But it's so much work.
Yes, hold me, Bean.
I need you to take a deep breath.
You're right.
I can't have you freaking out.
No, you're right.
Okay.
I'm excited to tear some stuff down.
Me too.
It's demo time!
Ew, it's like all mold, this.
It's like, how many decades worth of poops
have been in here?
[Ariel] You got it.
Here we go.
There it goes.
Kick!
That was good ninja kick.
[Ned] Yeah, that was awesome.
We have destroyed a lot.
Yeah.
But maybe our first DIY project could be
the sticky front door?
Yes!
Hey, Ariel.
Oh, Jesus, oh my goodness, okay.
You're doing great, sweetie!
[Ariel] No, that's not the
way you're supposed to do it!
Look out.
I'm pretty sure that
you just spread rat
turds all over the floor.
Ew, what?
Now we're going to finish the door
with this beautiful rich blue paint.
[Together] Ooh, yeah.
I'm getting some fumes, Ariel.
Would it make you feel better
if I put on a respirator?
Yeah.
Maybe I should just paint it and you can
give me feedback from...
Ned, that's like really thick.
What you actually...
Can you just like...
No, you're not doing it right.
I...
No, you're like actually
not doing it right.
Look at mine.
Can you just get over there?
Okay, okay, just look at mine.
you could see the lines there.
Can you just like...
But you can see the lines in it.
Maybe I need a respirator.
It doesn't fit, I don't think it fits.
See you got it way too thick here.
You got it too thick.
[Ned] Okay.
Seriously, seriously dizzy right now.
Every single time.
[Ariel] There we go.
[Ned] Oh yeah.
Hold that for me.
Well look at you.
What do you think of this?
Ariel, where are we
gonna put that knocker?
I like that knocker.
[Ariel] It's like, right there.
Is that too small?
No, I think it's good.
Too low?
No.
Nope.
Too high.
How do we tell how high is too high?
[Ariel] Perfect.
All right, let's check it out.
It looks great!
It's nice!
It's so much better than it was.
Well, Mrs. Fulmer, are you ready
to check out our new house?
[Ariel] Yes, I am.
Yep.
It's a work-in progress.
It's a start.
How are you feeling right now?
I feel good.
I'm happy to eat.
That was a tiring day.
That was a long day.
There's so many things
happening in our life right now.
I know.
And having a baby would
be crazy enough, but
to think about how our lives
will change having a baby...
[Ariel] And having a new house.
And having a new house.
It feels really special that
this place is ours.
And ours alone.
And we can do whatever we want.
Right.
Also when I think about how far we've come
on this journey...
Honey, we've been looking for
houses for like two years.
[Ariel] I know.
[Ned] A couple of weeks ago
we were seeing a mansion
that we totally couldn't afford.
[Ariel] But love.
[Ned] But love, then we
were able to compromise
on our needs versus our wants.
And when we put the new
door on our entrance
[Ariel] Yeah.
It was like, for just
a moment, I was like,
"Ah, this is what it's like!"
I felt that way the minute
we knocked through the wall.
[Ned] Cracking through some
of these walls was pretty fun.
This house might not be
perfect for everyone but.
[Ariel] It's perfect for us.
[Ned] It's perfect for us, yeah.
I like that.
It better be!
'Cause this baby is coming,
whether we like it or not.
That was my boob, but...
That was your boob?
No, I'm joking.
How's your chicken?
[Ned] Oh, really good.
[Ariel] Well that's unsafe.
Yeah, I think this whole thing's unsafe.